ANNOUNCER: Open content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu .
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Last
time, we ended up, we sort of
did this tag team thing,
Professor Guttag did the first
half, I did the second half of
the lecture, and the second
half of the lecture, we
started talking about
complexity.
Efficiency.
Orders of growth.
And that's what we're going to
spend today on, is talking
about that topic.
I'm going to use it
to build over the
next couple of lectures.
I want to remind you that we
were talking at a fairly high
level about complexity.
We're going to get down into
the weeds in a second here.
But the things we were trying
to stress were that it's an
important design decision, when
you are coming up with a
piece of code, as to what kind
of efficiency your code has.
And the second thing that we
talked about is this idea that
we want you to in fact learn
how to relate a choice you
make about a piece of
code to what the
efficiency is going to be.
So in fact, over the next thirty
or forty minutes, we're
going to show you a set of
examples of sort of canonical
algorithms, and the different
classes of complexity.
Because one of the things that
you want to do as a good
designer is to basically
map a new problem
into a known domain.
You want to take a new problem
and say, what does
this most look like?
What is the class of algorithm
that's-- that probably applies
to this, and how do I pull
something out of that, if you
like, a briefcase of possible
algorithms to solve?
All right, having said that,
let's do some examples.
I'm going to show you a sequence
of algorithms,
they're mostly simple
algorithms, that's OK.
But I want you to take away from
this how we reason about
the complexity of these
algorithms. And I'll remind
you, we said we're going to
mostly talk about time.
We're going to be counting the
number of basic steps it takes
to solve the problem.
So here's the first example
I want to do.
I'm going to write a function
to compute integer power
exponents. a to the b where
b is an integer.
And I'm going to do it only
using multiplication and
addition and some simple tests.
All right?
And yeah, I know it comes built
in, that's OK, what we
want to do is use it as an
example to look at it.
So I'm going to build something
that's going to do
iterative exponentiation.
OK?
And in fact, if you look at the
code up here, and it's on
your handout, the very first
one, x 1, right here-- if I
could ask you to look at it--
is a piece of code to do it.
And I'm less interested in the
code than how we're going to
analyze it, but let's look
at it for a second.
All right, you can see that
this little piece of code,
it's got a loop in there,
and what's it doing?
It's basically cycling
through the loop,
multiplying by a each time.
So first time through the
loop, the answer is 1.
Second time it-- sorry, as it
enters the loop, at the time
it enter-- exits,
the answer is a.
Next time through the loop
it goes to a squared.
it goes to a cubed.
And it's just gathering together
the multiplications
while counting down
the exponent.
And you can see it when we get
down to the end test here,
we're going to pop out of
there and we're going to
return the answer.
I could run it, it'll
do the right thing.
What I want to think about
though, is, how much
time does this take?
How many steps does it take
for this function to run?
Well, you can kind of
look at it, right?
The key part of that
is that WHILE loop.
And what are the steps
I want to count?
They're inside that loop--
I've got the wrong glasses so
I'm going to have to squint--
and we've got one test which
is a comparison, we've got
another test which is a
multiplication-- sorry, not a
test, we've got another step
which is a multiplication--
and another step that
is a subtraction.
So each time through the loop,
I'm doing three steps.
Three basic operations.
How many times do I go
through the loop?
Somebody help me out.
Hand up?
Sorry. b times.
You're right.
Because I keep counting down
each time around-- mostly I've
got to unload this candy, which
is driving me nuts, so--
thank you. b times.
So I've got to go 3 b steps.
All right, I've got to go
through the loop b times, I've
got three steps each time, and
then when I pop out of the
loop, I've got two more steps.
All right, I've got the
initiation of answer and the
return of it.
So I take 2 plus 3 b steps
to go through this loop.
OK.
So if b is 300, it takes 902
steps. b is 3000, it takes
9002 steps. b is 30,000
you get the point, it
takes 90,002 steps.
OK.
So the point here is, first of
all, I can count these things,
but the second thing you can
see is, as the size of the
problems get larger, that
additive constant, that 2,
really doesn't matter.
All right?
The difference between 90,000
steps and 90,002 steps, who
cares about the 2, right?
So, and typically, we're not
going to worry about those
additive constants.
The second one is, this
multiplicative constant here
is 3, in some sense also
isn't all that crucial.
Does it really matter to you
whether your code is going to
take 300 years or 900
years to run?
Problem is, how big
is that number?
So we're going to typically
also not worry about the
multiplicative constants.
This factor here.
What we really want to worry
about is, as the size of the
problem gets larger, how
does this thing grow?
How does the cost go up?
And so what we're going to
primarily talk about as a
consequence is the rate of
growth as the size of the
problem grows.
If it was, how much bigger does
this get as I make the
problem bigger?
And what that really says is,
that we're going to use this
using something we're
going to just
call asymptotic notation--
I love spelling this word--
meaning, as in the limit as
the size of the problem gets
bigger, how do I characterize
this growth?
All right?
You'll find out, if you go on
to some of the other classes
in course 6, there are a lot of
different ways that you can
measure this.
The most common one, and the
one we're going to use, is
what's often called
big Oh notation.
This isn't big Oh as in, oh my
God I'm shocked the markets
are collapsing, This is called
big Oh because we use the
Greek letter, capital letter,
omicron to represent it.
And the way we're going to do
this, or what this represents,
let me write this carefully for
you, big Oh notation is
basically going to be an upper
limit to the growth of a
function as the input grow--
as the input gets large.
Now we're going to see a bunch
of examples, and I know those
are words, let me give
you an example.
I would write f of x is in
big Oh of n squared.
And what does it say?
It says that function, f of x,
is bounded above, there's an
upper limit on it, that this
grows no faster than quadratic
in n, n squared.
OK.
And first of all, you say,
wait a minute, x and n?
Well, one of the things we're
going to see is x is the input
to this particular problem, n is
a measure of the size of x.
And we're going to talk about
how we come up with that. n
measures the size of x.
OK.
In this example I'd use b.
All right, as b get-- b is the
thing that's changing as I go
along here, but it could be
things like, how many elements
are there in a list if the input
is a list, could be how
many digits are there in a
string if the input's a
string, it could be the size of
the integer as we go along.
All right.?
And what we want to do then, is
we want to basically come
up with, how do we characterize
the growth--
God bless you-- of this problem
in terms of this
quadra-- sorry, terms of
this exponential growth
Now, one last piece of math.
I could cheat.
I said I just want
an upper bound.
I could get a really big upper
bound, this thing grows
exponentially.
That doesn't help me much.
Usually what I want to talk
about is what's the smallest
size class in which this
function grows?
With all of that, what that
says, is that this we would
write is order b.
That algorithm is linear.
You can see it.
I've said the product
was is 2 plus 3 b.
As I make b really large, how
does this thing grow?
It grows as b.
The 3 doesn't matter, it's
just a constant,
it's growing linearly.
Another way of saying it is,
if I, for example, increase
the size of the input by
10, the amount of time
increases by 10.
And that's a sign that
it's linear.
OK.
So there's one quick example.
Let's look at another example.
If you look at x 2, this one
right here in your handout.
OK.
This is another way of doing
exponentiation, but this one's
a recursive function.
All right?
So again, let's look at it.
What does it say to do?
Well, it's basically saying
a similar thing.
It says, if I am in the base
case, if b is equal to 1, the
answer is just a.
I could have used if b is equal
to 0, the answer is 1,
that would have also worked.
Otherwise, what do I say?
I say, ah, I'm in a nice
recursive way, a to the b is
the same as a times a
to the b minus 1.
And I've just reduced that
problem to a simpler version
of the same problem.
OK, and you can see that this
thing ought to unwrap, it's
going to keep extending out
those multiplications until
gets down to the base
case, going to
collapse them all together.
OK.
Now I want to know what's the
order of growth here?
What's the complexity of this?
Well, gee.
It looks like it's pretty
straightforward, right?
I've got one test there, and
then I've just got one thing
to do here, which has got
a subtraction and a
multiplication.
Oh, but how do I know how
long it takes to do x 2?
All right, we were counting
basic steps.
We don't know how long
it takes to do x 2.
So I'm going to show you
a little trick for
figuring that out.
And in particular, I'm going to
cheat slightly, I'm going
to use a little bit of abusive
mathematics, but I'm going to
show you a trick to
figure it out.
In the case of a recursive
exponentiator, I'm going to do
the following trick.
I'm going to let t of b be the
number of steps it takes to
solve the problem of size b.
OK, and I can figure this out.
I've got one test, I've got
a subtraction, I've got a
multiplication, that's three
steps, plus whatever number of
steps it takes to solve a
problem of size b minus 1.
All right, this is what's called
a recurrence relation,
there are actually cool
ways to solve them.
We can kind of eyeball it.
In particular, how would I
write an expression for
t of b minus 1?
Well the same way.
This is 3 plus 3 plus
t of b minus 2.
Right?
I'm using exactly the same
form to reduce this.
You know, you can see what's
going to happen.
If I reduce that, it would be
3 plus t of b minus 3, so in
general, this is 3 k plus
t of b minus k.
OK.
I'm just expanding it out.
When am I done?
How do I stop this?
Any suggestions?
Don't you hate it when
professors ask questions?
Yeah.
Actually, I think I want
b minus k equal to 1.
Right?
When this gets down to t of
1, I'm in the base case.
So I'm done when b minus
k equals 1, or k
equals b minus 1.
Right, that gets me down to the
base case, I'm solving a
problem with size 1, and in that
case, I've got two more
operations to do, so I plug this
all back in, I-- t of b
is I'm going to put k for b
minus 1 I get 3 b minus 1 plus
t of 1, so t of 1 is 2, so this
is 3 b minus 1 plus 2, or
3 b minus 1.
OK.
A whole lot of work
to basically say,
again, order b is linear.
But that's also nice, it lets
you see how the recursive
thing is simply unwrapping but
the complexity in terms of the
amount of time it takes is
going to be the same.
I owe you a candy.
Thank you.
OK.
At this point, if we stop,
you'll think all algorithms
are linear.
This is really boring.
But they're not.
OK?
So let me show you another way
I could do exponentiation.
Taking an advantage
of a trick.
I want to solve a to the b.
Here's another way
I could do that.
OK.
If b is even, then a to the b
is the same as a squared all
to the b over 2.
All right, just move
the 2's around.
It's the same thing.
You're saying, OK, so what?
Well gee, notice.
This is a primitive operation.
That's a primitive operation.
But in one step, I've reduced
this problem in half.
I didn't just make
it one smaller, I
made it a half smaller.
That's a nice deal.
OK.
But I'm not always going
to have b as even.
If b is odd, what do I do?
Well, go back to what
I did before.
Multiply a by a to
the b minus 1.
You know, that's nice, right?
Because if b was odd, then b
minus one is even, which means
on the next step, I can cut
the problem in half again.
OK?
All right. x 3, as you can see
right here, does exactly that.
OK?
You can take a quick look at
it, even with the wrong
glasses on, it says if a--
sorry, b is equal to 1, I'm
just going to return a.
Otherwise there's that funky
little test. I'll do the
remainder multiplied by 2,
because these are integers,
that gives me back an integer,
I just check to see if it's
equal to b, that tells me
whether it's even or odd.
And in the even case, I'd
square, divide by half, call
this again: in the odd case,
I go b minus 1 and
then multiply by a.
I'll let you chase it through,
it does work.
What I want to look
at is, what's the
order of growth here?
This is a little different,
right?
It's going to take a little bit
more work, so let's see if
we can do it.
In the b even case, again I'm
going to let t of b be the
number of steps I want
to go through.
And we can kind of eyeball
this thing, right?
If b is even, I've got a test to
see if b is equal to 1, and
then I've got to do the
remainder, the multiplication,
and the test, I'm up to four.
And then in the even case, I've
got to do a square and
the divide.
So I've got six steps, plus
whatever it takes to solve the
problem size b over 2, right?
Because that's the recursive
call. b as odd, well I can go
through the same
kind of thing.
I've got the same first four
steps, I've got a check to see
is it 1, I got a check to see if
it's even, and then in the
odd case, I've got to subtract 1
from b, that's a fifth step,
I've got to go off and solve
the recursive problem, and
then I'm going to do one more
multiplication, so it's 6
plus, in this case,
t of b minus 1.
Because it's now solving
a one-smaller problem.
On the next step though, this,
we get substituted by that.
Right, on the next step, I'm
back in the even case, it's
going to take six more steps,
plus t of b minus 1.
Oops, sorry about
that, over 2.
Because b minus 1 is now even.
Don't sweat the details here,
I just want you to see the
reason it goes through it.
What I now have, though,
is a nice thing.
It says, in either case, in
general, t of b-- and this is
where I'm going to abuse
notation a little bit-- but I
can basically bound it by t, 12
steps plus t of b over 2.
And the abuse is, you know,
it's not quite right, it
depends upon whether it's all
ready, but you can see in
either case, after 12 steps, 2
runs through this and down to
a problem size b over 2.
Why's that nice?
Well, that then says after
another 12 steps, we're down
to a problem with size
t of b over 4.
And if I pull it out one more
level, it's 12 plus 12 plus t
of b over 8, which in general is
going to be, after k steps,
12 k because I'll have 12 of
those to add up, plus t of b
over 2 to the k.
When am I done?
When do I get down
to the base case?
Somebody help me out.
What am I looking for?
Yeah.
You're jumping slightly ahead of
me, but basically, I'm done
when this is equal
to 1, right?
Because I get down to the base
case, so I'm done when b u is
over 2 to the k is equal to 1,
and you're absolutely right,
that's when k is log
base 2 of b.
You're sitting a long ways back,
I have no idea if I'll
make it this far or not.
Thank you.
OK.
There's some constants
in there, but this
is order log b.
Logarithmic.
This matters.
This matters a lot.
And I'm going to show you an
example in a second, just to
drive this home, but notice
the characteristics.
In the first two cases,
the problem reduced
by 1 at each step.
Whether it was recursive
or iterative.
That's a sign that it's
probably linear.
This case, I reduced the size
of the problem in half.
It's a good sign that this is
logarithmic, and I'm going to
come back in a second to why
logs are a great thing.
Let me show you one more class,
though, about-- sorry,
let me show you two more classes
of algorithms. Let's
look at the next one g-- and
there's a bug in your handout,
it should be g of n and m, I
apologize for that, I changed
it partway through and
didn't catch it.
OK.
Order of growth here.
Anybody want to volunteer
a guess?
Other than the TAs, who know?
OK.
Let's think it through.
I've got two loops.
All right?
We already saw with one of the
loops, you know, it looked
like it might be linear,
depending on what's inside of
it, but let's think
about this.
I got two loops with g.
What's g do?
I've got an initialization of
x, and then I say, for i in
the range, so that's basically
from 0 up to n minus
1, what do I do?
Well, inside of there, I've got
another loop, for j in the
range from 0 up to m minus 1.
What's the complexity
of that inner loop?
Sorry?
OK.
You're doing the whole
thing for me.
What's the complexity just
of this inner loop here?
Just this piece.
How many times do I go
through that loop? m.
Right?
I'm going to get back to your
answer in a second, because
you're heading in the
right direction.
The inner loop, this part
here, I do m times.
There's one step inside of it.
Right?
How many times do I go
through that loop?
Ah, n times, because for each
value of i, I'm going to do
that m thing, so that is, close
to what you said, right?
The order complexity here, if
I actually write it, would
be-- sorry, order n times m, and
if m was equal to n, that
would be order n squared,
and this is quadratic.
And that's a different
behavior.
OK.
What am I doing?
Building up examples of
algorithms. Again, I want you
to start seeing how to map the
characteristics of the code--
the characteristics of the
algorithm, let's not call it
the code-- to the complexity.
I'm going to come back to that
in a second with that, but I
need to do one more example,
and I've got to use my
high-tech really expensive
props.
Right.
So here's the fourth or fifth,
whatever we're up to, I guess
fifth example.
This is an example of a problem
called Towers of Hanoi.
Anybody heard about
this problem?
A few tentative hands.
OK.
Here's the story as
I am told it.
There's a temple in the
middle of Hanoi.
In that temple, there
are three very large
diamond-encrusted posts, and on
those posts are sixty-four
disks, all of a different
size.
And they're, you know, covered
with jewels and all sorts of
other really neat stuff.
There are a set of priests in
that temple, and their task is
to move the entire stack of
sixty-four disks from one post
to a second post. When they do
this, you know, the universe
ends or they solve the financial
crisis in Washington
or something like that actually
good happens, right?
Boy, none of you have 401k's,
you're not even wincing at
that thing.
All right.
The rules, though, are, they
can only move one disk at a
time, and they can never cover
up a smaller disk with a
larger disk.
OK.
Otherwise you'd just move the
whole darn stack, OK?
So we want to solve
that problem.
We want to write a piece of
code that helps these guys
out, so I'm going to show
you an example.
Let's see if we can figure
out how to do this.
So, we'll start with
the easy one.
Moving a disk of size 1.
OK, that's not so bad.
Moving a stack of size 2, if I
want to go there, I need to
put this one temporarily over
here so I can move the bottom
one before I move it over.
Moving a stack of size 3, again,
if I want to go over
there, I need to make sure I
can put the spare one over
here before I move the bottom
one, I can't cover up any of
the smaller ones with
the larger one, but
I can get it there.
Stack of size 4, again I'm going
there, so I'm going to
do this initially, no I'm not,
I'm going to start again.
I'm going to go there initially,
so I can move this
over here, so I can get the base
part of that over there,
I want to put that one there
before I put this over here,
finally I get to the point where
I can move the bottom
one over, now I've got to be
really careful to make sure
that I don't cover up the bottom
one in the wrong way
before I get to the stage where
I wish they were posts
and there you go.
All right?
[APPLAUSE]
I mean, I can make money at
Harvard Square doing this
stuff, right?
All right, you ready
to do five?
Got the solution?
Not so easy to see.
All right, but this is actually
a great one of those
educational moments.
This is a great example
to think recursively.
If I wanted to think about this
problem recursively--
what do I mean by thinking
recursively?
How do I reduce this to a
smaller-size problem in the
same instant?
And so, if I do that, this
now becomes really easy.
If I want to move this stack
here, I'm going to take a
stack of size n minus 1, move
it to the spare spot, now I
can move the base disk over,
and then I'm going to move
that stack of size n
minus 1 to there.
That's literally
what I did, OK?
So there's the code.
Called towers.
I'm just going to have you--
let you take a look at it.
I'm giving it an argument,
which is the size of the
stack, and then just labels
for the three posts.
A from, a to, and a spare.
And in fact, if we look at
this-- let me just pop it over
to the other side--
OK, I can move a tower, I'll say
of size 2, from, to, and
spare, and that was
what I did.
And if I want to move towers,
let's say, size 5, from, to,
and spare, there are
the instructions
for how to move it.
We ain't going to
do sixty-four.
OK.
All right.
So it's fun, and I got a little
bit of applause out of
it, which is always nice for me,
but I also showed you how
to think about it recursively.
Once you hear that description,
it's easy to
write the code, in fact.
This is a place where the
recursive version of it is
much easier to think about
than the iterative one.
But what I really want to talk
about is, what's the order of
growth here?
What's the complexity
of this algorithm?
And again, I'm going to do it
with a little bit of abusive
notation, and it's a little more
complicated, but we can
kind of look at.
All right?
Given the code up there, if I
want to move a tower of size
n, what do I have to do?
I've got to test to see if I'm
in the base case, and if I'm
not, then I need to move a tower
of size n minus 1, I
need to move a tower of size
1, and I need to move a
second-- sorry about that--
a second tower of
size n minus 1.
OK. t of 1 I can also reduce.
In the case of a tower of size
1, basically there are two
things to do, right?
I've got to do the test, and
then I just do the move.
So the general formula is that.
Now.
You might look at that and say,
well that's just a lot
like what we had over here.
Right?
We had some additive constant
plus a simpler version of the
same problem reduced
in size by 1.
But that two matters.
So let's look at it.
How do I rea-- replace the
expression FOR t of n minus 1?
Substitute it in again. t
of n minus 1 is 3 plus 2
t of n minus 2.
So this is 3, plus 2 times
3, plus 4 t minus 2.
OK.
And if I substitute it again, I
get 3 plus 2 times 3 plus 4
times 3 plus 8 t n minus 3.
This is going by a little
fast. I'm just
substituting in.
I'm going to skip some steps.
But basically if I do this, I
end up with 3 times 1 plus 2
plus 4 to 2 to the k
minus 1 for all of
those terms, plus 2--
I want to do this right, 2 to
the k, sorry-- t of n minus k.
OK.
Don't sweat the details, I'm
just expanding it out.
What I want you to see is,
because I've got two versions
of that problem.
The next time down I've
got four versions.
Next time down I've got
eight versions.
And in fact, if I substitute, I
can solve for this, I'm done
when this is equal to 1.
If you substitute it all
in, you get basically
order 2 to the n.
Exponential.
That's a problem.
Now, it's also the case that
this is fundamentally what
class this algorithm falls
into, it is going to take
exponential amount of time.
But it grows pretty rapidly, as
n goes up, and I'm going to
show you an example
in a second.
Again, what I want you
to see is, notice the
characteristic of that.
That this recursive call had two
sub-problems of a smaller
size, not one.
And that makes a
big difference.
So just to show you how big a
difference it makes, let's run
a couple of numbers.
Let's suppose n is 1000,
and we're running
at nanosecond speed.
We have seen log, linear,
quadratic, and exponential.
So, again, there could be
constants in here, but just to
give you a sense of this.
If I'm running at nanosecond
speed, n, the size of the
problem, whatever it is, is
1000, and I've got a log
algorithm, it takes 10
nanoseconds to complete.
If you blink, you miss it.
If I'm running a linear
algorithm, it'll take one
microsecond to complete.
If I'm running a quadratic
algorithm, it'll take one
millisecond to complete.
And if I'm running
an exponential
algorithm, any guesses?
I hope Washington doesn't take
this long to fix my 401k plan.
All right?
10 to the 284 years.
As Emeril would say, pow!
That's a some spicy whatever.
All right.
Bad jokes aside, what's
the point?
You see, these classes have
really different performance.
Now this is a little
misleading.
These are all really fast, so
just to give you another set
of examples, I'm not
going to do the--
If I had a problem where the log
one took ten milliseconds,
then the linear one would take
a second, the quadratic one
would take 16 minutes.
So you can see, even the
quadratic ones can
blow up in a hurry.
And this goes back to
the point I tried
to make last time.
Yes, the computers are really
fast. But the problems can
grow much faster than you can
get a performance boost out of
the computer.
And you really, wherever
possible, want to avoid that
exponential algorithm, because
that's really deadly.
Yes.
All right.
The question is, is there a
point where it'll quit.
Yeah, when the power goes out,
or-- so let me not answer it
quite so facetiously.
We'd be mostly talking
about time.
In fact, if I ran one of these
things, it would just keep
crunching away.
It will probably quit at some
point because of space issues,
unless I'm writing an algorithm
that is using no
additional space.
Right.
Those things are going to stack
up, and eventually it's
going to run out of space.
And that's more likely to
happen, but, you know.
The algorithm doesn't know that
it's going to take this
long to compute, it's just busy
crunching away, trying to
see if it can make it happen.
OK.
Good question, thank you.
All right.
I want to do one more extended
example here., because we've
got another piece to do, but I
want to capture this, because
it's important, so let me
again try and say it the
following way.
I want you to recognize classes
of algorithms and
match what you see in the
performance of the algorithm
to the complexity of
that algorithm.
All right?
Linear algorithms tend to
be things where, at one
pass-through, you reduce
the problem by a
constant amount, by one.
If you reduce it by two, it's
going to be the same thing.
Where you go from problem of
size n to a problem of
size n minus 1.
A log algorithm typically is one
where you cut the size of
the problem down by some
multiplicative factor.
You reduce it in half.
You reduce it in third.
All right?
Quadratic algorithms
tend to have this--
I was about to say additive,
wrong term-- but
doubly-nested, triply-nested
things are likely to be
quadratic or cubic algorithms,
all right, because you know--
let me not confuse things--
double-loop quadratic
algorithm, because you're doing
one set of things and
you're doing it some other
number of times, and that's a
typical signal that that's
what you have there.
OK.
And then the exponentials, as
you saw is when typically I
reduce the problem of one size
into two or more sub-problems
of a smaller size.
And you can imagine this gets
complex and there's lots of
interesting things to do to
look to the real form, but
those are the things that
you should see.
Now.
Two other things, before we
do this last example.
One is, I'll remind you, what
we're interested in is
asymptotic growth.
How does this thing grow as I
make the problem size big?
And I'll also remind you, and
we're going to see this in the
next example, we talked
about looking at
the worst case behavior.
In these cases there's no best
case worst case, it's just
doing one computation.
We're going to see an example
of that in a second.
What we really want to worry
about, what's the worst case
that happens.
And the third thing I want you
to keep in mind is, remember
these are orders of growth.
It is certainly possible, for
example, that a quadratic
algorithm could run faster
than a linear algorithm.
It depends on what the input is,
it depends on, you know,
what the particular cases are.
So it is not the case that,
on every input, a linear
algorithm is always
going to be better
than a quadratic algorithm.
It is just in general that's
going to hold true, and that's
what I want you to see.
OK.
I want to do one last example.
I'm going to take a little bit
more time on it, because it's
going to both reinforce these
ideas, but it's also going to
show us how we have to think
about what's a primitive
step., and in a particular,
how do data structures
interact with this analysis?
Here I've just been running
integers, it's pretty simple,
but if I have a data structure,
I'm going to have
to worry about that
a little bit more.
So let's look at that.
And the example I want to look
at is, suppose I want to
search a list that I know is
sorted, to see if an element's
in the list. OK?
So the example I'm going to
do, I'm going to search a
sorted list. All right.
If you flip to the second side
of your handout, you'll see
that I have a piece of code
there, that does this-- let
me, ah, I didn't want to
do that, let me back up
slightly-- this is the algorithm
called search.
And let's take a look at it.
OK?
Basic idea, before I even look
at the code, is pretty simple.
If I've got a list that is
sorted, in let's call it, just
in increasing order, and I
haven't said what's in the
list, could be numbers, could
be other things, for now,
we're going to just assume
they're integers.
The easy thing to do would be
the following: start at the
front end of the list, check
the first element.
If it's the thing I'm looking
for, I'm done.
It's there.
If not, move on to
the next element.
And keep doing that.
But if, at any point, I get to
a place in the list where the
thing I'm looking for is smaller
than the element in
the list, I know everything else
in the rest of the list
has to be bigger than that,
I don't have to
bother looking anymore.
It says the element's
not there.
I can just stop.
OK.
So that's what this piece
of code does here.
Right.?
I'm going to set up a variable
to say, what's the answer I
want to return, is
it there or not.
Initially it's got that
funny value none.
I'm going to set up an index,
which is going to tell me
where to look, starting at the
first part of the list, right?
And then, when I got--
I'm also going to count how many
comparisons I do, just so
I can see how much work
I do here, and then
notice what it does.
It says while the index is
smaller than the size of the
list, I'm not at the end of the
list, and I don't have an
answer yet, check.
So I'm going to check to see
if-- really can't read that
thing, let me do it this way--
right, I'm going to increase
the number of compares, and I'm
going to check to say, is
the thing I'm looking for at
the i'th spot in the list?
Right, so s of i saying, given
the list, look at the i'th
element, is it the same thing?
If it is, OK.
Set the answer to true.
Which means, next time through
the loop, that's going to pop
out and return an answer.
If it's not, then check to see,
is it smaller than that
element in the current
spot of the list?
And if that's true, it says
again, everything else in the
list has to be bigger than this,
thing can't possibly be
in the list, I'm taking
advantage of the ordering, I
can set the answer to false,
change i to go to the next
one, and next time through the
loop, I'm going to pop out and
print it out.
OK?
Right.
Order of growth here.
What do you think?
Even with these glasses on,
I can see no hands up, any
suggestions?
Somebody help me out.
What do you think the order
of growth is here?
I've got a list, walk you
through it an element at a
time, do I look at each
element of the
list more than once?
Don't think so, right?
So, what does this suggest?
Sorry?
Constant.
Ooh, constant says, no matter
what the length of the list
is, I'm going to take the
same amount of time.
And I don't think that's
true, right?
If I have a list ten times
longer, it's going to take me
more time, so-- not a
bad guess, I'm still
reward you, thank you.
Somebody else.
Yeah.
Linear.
Why?
You're right, by the
way, but why?
Yeah.
All right, so the answer was
it's linear, which is
absolutely right.
Although for a reason
we're going to
come back in a second.
Oh, thank you, I hope your
friends help you out with
that, thank you.
Right?
You can see that this
ought to be linear,
because what am I doing?
I'm walking down the list. So
one of the things I didn't
say, it's sort of implicit here,
is what is the thing I
measuring the size of
the problem in?
What's the size of the list?
And if I'm walking down the
list, this is probably order
of the length of the list s,
because I'm looking at each
element once.
Now you might say,
wait a minute.
Thing's ordered, if I stop part
way through and I throw
away half the list, doesn't
that help me?
And the answer is yes, but it
doesn't change the complexity.
Because what did we say?
We're measuring the
worst case.
The worst case here is, the
things not in the list, in
which case I've got to go all
the way through the list to
get to the end.
OK.
Now, having said that, and I've
actually got a subtlety
I'm going to come back to in a
second, there ought to be a
better way to do this.
OK?
And here's the better
way to think about.
I'll just draw out sort of a
funny representation of a
list. These are sort of the
cells, if you like, in memory
that are holding the elements
of the list. What we've been
saying is, I start
here and look.
If it's there, I'm done.
If not, I go there.
If it's there, I'm done, if not,
I keep walking down, and
I only stop when I get to a
place where the element I'm
looking for is smaller than
the value in the list., in
which case I know the
rest of this is too
big and I can stop.
But I still have to go
through the list.
There's a better way to think
about this, and in fact
Professor Guttag has already
hinted at this in the last
couple of lectures.
The better way to think about
this is, suppose, rather than
starting at the beginning, I
just grabbed some spot at
random, like this one.
And I look at that value.
If it's the value I'm looking
for, boy, I ought to go to
Vegas, I'm really lucky.
And I'm done, right?
If not, what could I do?
Well, I could look at the value
here, and compare it to
the value I'm trying to find,
and say the following; if the
value I'm looking for is bigger
than this value, where
do I need to look?
Just here.
All right?
Can't possibly be there,
because I know
this thing is over.
On the other hand, if the value
I'm looking for here--
sorry, the value I'm looking for
is smaller than the value
I see here, I just need
to look here.
All right?
Having done that, I could do the
same thing, so I suppose I
take this branch, I can pick a
spot like, say, this one, and
look there.
Because there, I'm done,
if not, I'm either
looking here or there.
And I keep cutting
the problem down.
OK.
Now, having said that, where
should I pick to
look in this list?
I'm sorry?
Halfway.
Why?
You're right, but why?
Yeah.
So the answer, in case you
didn't hear it, was, again, if
I'm a gambling person, I could
start like a way down here.
All right?
If I'm gambling, I'm saying,
gee, if I'm really lucky,
it'll be only on this side, and
I've got a little bit of
work to do, but if I'm unlucky,
I'm scrawed, the past
pluperfect of screwed, OK.,
or a Boston fish.
I'll look at the rest of that
big chunk of the list, and
that's a pain.
So halfway is the right thing
to do, because at each step,
I'm guaranteed to throw away at
least half the list. Right?
And that's nice.
OK.
What would you guess the order
of growth here is?
Yeah.
Why?
Good.
Exactly.
Right?
Again, if you didn't hear it,
the answer was it's log.
Because I'm cutting down the
problem in half at each time.
You're right, but there's
something we have to do to add
to that, and that's the last
thing I want to pick up on.
OK.
Let's look at the code--
actually, let's test this out
first before we do it.
So I've added, as Professor
Guttag did-- ah, should have
said it this way, let's write
the code for it first, sorry
about that--
OK, I'm going to write a little
thing called b search.
I'm going to call it down here
with search, which is simply
going to call it, and then
print an answer out.
In binary search-- ah, there's
that wonderful phrase, this is
called a version of binary
search, just like you saw
bin-- or bi-section methods,
when we were doing numerical
things-- in binary search, I
need to keep track of the
starting point and the
ending point of the
list I'm looking at.
Initially, it's the beginning
and the end of it.
And when I do this test, what I
want to do, is say I'm going
to pick the middle spot, and
depending on the test, if I
know it's in the upper half, I'm
going to set my start at
the mid point and the end stays
the same, if it's in the
front half I'm going to keep
the front the same and I'm
going to change the endpoint.
And you can see that
in this code here.
Right?
What does it say to do?
It says, well I'm going to print
out first and last, just
so you can see it, and then I
say, gee, if last minus first
is less than 2, that is, if
there's no more than two
elements left in the list, then
I can just check those
two elements, and return
the answer.
Otherwise, we find
the midpoint, and
notice what it does.
First, it's pointing to the
beginning of the list, which
initially might be down here at
0 but after a while, might
be part way through.
And to that, I simply
add a halfway
point, and then I check.
If it's at that point, I'm done,
if not, if it's greater
than the value I'm looking
for, I either take
one half or the other.
OK.
You can see that thing is
cutting down the problem in
half each time, which is good,
but there's one more thing I
need to deal with.
So let's step through this
with a little more care.
And I keep saying, before
we do it, let's just
actually try it out.
So I'm going to go over
here, and I'm going
to type test search--
I can type-- and if you look at
your handout, it's just a
sequence of tests that
I'm going to do.
OK.
So initially, I'm going to set
up the list to be the first
million integers.
Yeah, it's kind of simple, but
it gives me an ordered list of
these things, And let's run it.
OK.
So I'm first going to look for
something that's not in the
list, I'm going to see, is minus
1 in this list, so it's
going to be at the far end,
and if I do that in
the basic case, bam.
Done.
All right?
The basic, that primary search,
because it looks at
the first element, says
it's smaller than
everything else, I'm done.
If I look in the binary case,
takes a little longer.
Notice the printout here.
The printout is simply telling
me, what are the
ranges of the search.
And you can see it wrapping its
way down, cutting in half
at each time until it
gets there, but it
takes a while to find.
All right.
Let's search to see though now
if a million is in this list,
or 10 million, whichever way
I did this, it must be a
million, right?
In the basic case, oh,
took a little while.
Right, in the binary
case, bam.
In fact, it took the same number
of steps as it did in
the other case, because
each time I'm cutting
it down by a half.
OK.
That's nice.
Now, let's do the following;
if you look right here, I'm
going to set this now to--
I'm going to change my range
to 10 million, I'm going to
first say, gee, is a
million in there,
using the basic search.
It is.
Now, I'm going to say, is 10
million in this, using the
basic search.
We may test your hypothesis,
about how long does it take,
if I time this really well, I
ought to be able to end when
it finds it, which should
be right about now.
That was pure luck.
But notice how much
longer it took.
On the other hand, watch what
happens with binary.
Is the partway one there?
Yeah.
Is the last one there?
Wow.
I think it took one more step.
Man, that's exactly what
logs should do, right?
I make the problem ten times
bigger, it takes one
more step to do it.
Whereas in the linear case, I
make it ten times bigger, it
takes ten times longer to run.
OK.
So I keep saying I've got one
thing hanging, it's the last
thing I want to do, but I wanted
you see how much of a
difference this makes.
But let's look a little more
carefully at the code for
binary search-- for search 1.
What's the complexity
of search 1?
Well, you might say it's
constant, right?
It's only got two things to do,
except what it really says
is, that the complexity of
search 1 is the same as the
complexity of b search,
because that's
the call it's doing.
So let's look at b search.
All right?
We've got the code for
b search up there.
First step, constant, right?
Nothing to do.
Second step, hm.
That also looks constant,
you think?
Oh but wait a minute.
I'm accessing s.
I'm accessing a list. How long
does it take for me to get the
nth element of a list?
That might not be a
primitive step.
And in fact, it depends
on how I store a list.
So, for example, in this case,
I had lists that I knew were
made out of integers.
As a consequence, I have
a list of ints.
I might know, for example,
that it takes four memory
chunks to represent one
int, just for example.
And to find the i'th element,
I'm simply going to take the
starting point, that point at
the beginning of memory where
the list is, plus 4 times i,
that would tell me how many
units over to go, and that's the
memory location I want to
look for the i'th element
of the list.
And remember, we said we're
going to assume a random
access model, which says, as
long as I know the location,
it takes a constant amount of
time to get to that point.
So if the-- if I knew the
lists were made of just
integers, it'd be really
easy to figure it out.
Another way of saying it is,
this takes constant amount of
time to figure out where to
look, it takes constant amount
of time to get there, so in fact
I could treat indexing
into a list as being
a basic operation.
But we know lists can be
composed of anything.
Could be ints, could be floats,
could be a combination
of things, some ints, some
floats, some lists, some
strings, some lists of
lists, whatever.
And in that case, in general
lists, I need to figure out
what's the access time.
And here I've got a choice.
OK, one of the ways I could
do would be the following.
I could have a pointer to the
beginning of the list where
the first element here is the
actual value, and this would
point to the next element in
the list. Or another way of
saying it is, the first part
of the cell could be some
encoding of how many cells do
I need to have to store the
value, and then I've got some
way of telling me where to get
the next element of the list.
And this would point to value,
and this would point off
someplace in memory.
Here's the problem with that
technique, and by the way, a
number of programming
languages use
this, including Lisp.
The problem with that technique,
while it's very
general, is how long does it
take me to find the i'th
element of the list?
Oh fudge knuckle.
OK.
I've got to go to the first
place, figure out how far over
to skip, go to the next place,
figure out how far over to
skip, eventually I'll
be out the door.
I've got to count my way down,
which means that the access
would be linear in the length
of the list to find the i'th
element of the list, and that's
going to increase the
complexity.
There's an alternative, which
is the last point I want to
make, which is instead what I
could do, I should have said
these things are called linked
lists, we'll come back to
those, another way to do it,
is to have the start of the
list be at some point in memory,
and to have each one
of the successive cells
in memory point off
to the actual value.
Which may take up some arbitrary
amount of memory.
In that case, I'm back
to this problem.
And as a consequence, access
time in the list is constant,
which is what I want.
Now, to my knowledge, most
implementations of Python use
this way of storing lists,
whereas Lisp
and Scheme do not.
The message I'm trying to get
to here, because I'm running
you right up against time, is
I have to be careful about
what's a primitive step.
With this, if I can assume
that accessing the i'th
element of a list is constant,
then you can't see that the
rest of that analysis looks just
like the log analysis I
did before, and each step, no
matter which branch I'm
taking, I'm cutting the
problem down in half.
And as a consequence,
it is log.
And the last piece of this, is
as said, I have to make sure I
know what my primitive elements
are, in terms of
operations.
Summary: I want you to recognize
different classes of
algorithms. I'm not going
to repeat them.
We've seen log, we've seen
linear, we've seen quadratic,
we've seen exponential.
One of the things you should
begin to do, is to recognize
what identifies those classes of
algorithms, so you can map
your problems into
those ranges.
And with that, good
luck on Thursday.